uh when you've been to award shows the
oscars of the government you've all
taken your parents
which is i mean that seems you know to
have four of you all do this touching i
don't think it's lovely
now ryan your mom she i mean i'm sure
she likes meeting celebrities but isn't
it the gift room is really her thing she
enjoys
i don't want to out my mom like this
i will tell a funny story about that
picture though which is that my mom was
convinced that year by her friend that
beehives were gonna be all the rage
and if you didn't have a beehive you'd
feel embarrassed and it turned out to be
the opposite it was a natural hair vibe
and my mom sat in front of
rachel wise and uh her hair was so high
that rachel had to keep
my mom kept sinking in her chair
and i didn't know what to do because i
was you know i wanted to have a nice
night so i i didn't know meryl streep
but she was sitting next to me and i
said in a commercial break do would you
would you mind just telling my mom you
like her hair you know
and she was like i got this and then the
commercial went she goes do you know i
wish i was going to do a beehive and i
wish i had
my
does she already know does she already
know that story your mom my mom yeah oh
no
yikes
where did the dog the dog isn't in the
film
you had a dog didn't you
oh no i found a dog on the uh on the
film okay
would you like me to tell that story
yeah
i can give it a go if you want
a big old dog
big old dog
three legs
right yeah that's about right
no they uh
so i i was staying at this sort of go-to
movie guy house in atlanta where you
know when they showed me the the house
they were like you know liam hemsworth
and miley cyrus just stayed here so
and they gave me one of these you know
which i thought was untoward
but it was they're very precious about
the house what i didn't realize was that
there's a strict no dogs policy and then
i was going to work one morning and
there's a little dog it's minus it's
below zero and i thought oh what can it
what harm can it do
and i let it in the house when i came
back
from work it was like a fecal jackson
pollock
it was just
it was everywhere
it was like did he have help
i was like like looking up like did he
get a ladder
how does he was he still alive
[Laughter]
and uh so then i had to clean it all up
and then i had to hide the dog and i
spent like two weeks hiding this dog
and uh you know when it was over the
last day i didn't know what i was going
to do with it and actually your driver
beau
said that his um his father had just
lost his dog of 16 years and so beau
took this little dog and he went and
lived on a lake with a hundred acres and
he went to you know literally oh that's
a nice story that's a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so dead that dog
he died after the incidentally
end of dawg
you do have a connection i i've got a
weird intro to show business via was it
your uncle i believe yeah that's right
so he
so
was your uncle living with you
yes
and did you walk into the room once
i i walked into the room once and he was
um um
bedazzling a uh a sequined white
jumpsuit and he and he said that he was
gonna be elvis for a little while
and and and you know what i'd like to
help and and uh
he said absolutely what do you need me
to do so i became his head of security
and he got my whole family in on the act
my mother was a backup singer and um
[Music]
honestly it was one of the greatest
performances i've ever seen
i mean you've been sincere i mean it was
it was really affecting
no no he yeah he i mean what i admired
about what he was doing was that he
looked nothing like elvis you know
he didn't attempt to he had a mustache
and very little hair
but my god he just he just became him
and uh you know he would end every show
with uh suspicious minds
and he would get on his knees and and
often with tears in his eyes he would he
would sing to some imaginary woman and
beg her not to leave
and
we were transported from this mall in my
small town
in ontario to to to that
i imagined it was a kitchen and she was
trying to leave and we were just in that
moment every night and it was
it was incredible and and honestly one
of the best like
acting lessons i've ever i ever had yeah
i wish i could have helped out with
those sequins
i could use a little i would have liked
that how old were you at when you were
doing security
i want to say six
it's quite quiet
i just had two tiny guns
wait so there's no photo
no ah i painted i painted a picture bro
yeah
young entrepreneur weren't you
i wouldn't say that no
but didn't your father what did he eat
he wanted you to sell was it cellophane
you wanted to sell
my parents came upon a
truck of cellophane somehow
i was asked not to ask too many
questions i didn't
i just suddenly there was a basement
filled with cellophane and uh
they encouraged me to go to school and
see if i could sell it to my teachers or
put a few in my backpack and try and
hock them at recess you know
convince kids that they might be good uh
stocking stuffers for their parents
what are the uses of cellophane
how did it go
what do you mean what's the use of zelda
i didn't i i know the name but i don't
know what you do with it you know you
wrap sandwiches in it it keeps things
fresh oh
okay
i'm sorry no no no it was an important
question you needed to ask her
i'm not doing a good job of selling it
obviously but yeah did you did you sell
it
there's still some left if you're
interested
it'd be nice for someone the dream was
someone would just say i'll take all of
it
never happened
that's a weird story
it is a bit weird now you tell it yes
seems like a good idea at the time we
are going to focus on the early dancing
career of mr ryan costing
now make sense the only video you have
tonight is yeah yeah
so the dance troupe you were in can you
tell us about because apparently young
dancers they can be quite vicious
it's a cutthroat business
and i had to get out
i i was on some
kind of a canadian star search and uh i
somehow made it to the finals and uh my
main competition were these two
uh twins who were tap dancers and they
were dancing to phil collins uh two
hearts
and they had big heart-shaped bows and
they were just uh
they were the ones to beat so
i remember uh you know wishing them luck
and going on stage and i was getting
ready to start was dancing the everybody
dance now by cnc music factory of course
getting ready to start which is this is
how you started a winning dance number
if you want to know
let me get out of your hand tonight
and i look up into the into the uh just
off stage and the two twins are standing
there like the
twins from the shining
and they're just going like this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i was like all right
that means war is life
i just shimmied my way all the way to
to that trophy to that tiny little
trophy
because i i was gonna is this the same
dream i was gonna say it's an all it's
an all girl troupe but obviously it's
not you're in it right
but
you are the only boy in it yeah that was
the was that the that was the point that
was the gimmick they let me dance there
for free because i was a guy because if
you
had a guy you you would win
oh okay yeah so are you ready to see the
the
dance stylist
uh i believe you're dancing to kathy
dennis's classic touch me
um uh did the troupe have a name ryan
it was elite dance studio
and how old are you in this one
old enough to know better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
i wish i could say someone said here you
have to wear this
but that was my idea i thought i have a
vision for this number
and silver hammer pants
they are br the silver hammer plants are
i don't think we know we gave them
enough of a shot we gave up with hammer
but i think we should we should have
kept them going
no yeah
[Music]
you